[Musique]
Jean-Marie waouh vous avez écrit que la
France était un pays imaginaire pourquoi
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
ça veut dire que c'est un pays où les
rêves
comptent presque plus que les réalités
et parce que c'est un pays qui a été
façonné par les écrivains par la
religion par des fantasmes et quand vous
voyez la composition géologique de la
France c'est un vrai semblable parce que
la voix il y a le poids de la religion
chrétienne que on pourrait même dire que
nos querelles le jour lui sont les
querelles théologiques laïciser il y a
le poids de la monarchie
il y a le poids de la Révolution il y a
le poids de tous ces régimes qui sont
succédés et puis derrière tout ça il y a
ce qui est formidable c'est tous ces
écrivains qui ont rêvé la France et qui
ont fini par façonner la France on est à
la fois
l'exemple très très précis quel par
exemple Jean-Jacques Rousseau Jacques
Rousseau c'est quand même quelqu'un
un bip
mentale c'est un génial écrivain
sentimentale et quand même il est très
perturbé et qui va essayer de créer de
façonner la Nouvelle France et la
révolution va s'inspirer de ses idées
donc vous voyez à chaque fois les
écrivains jouent un très très grand rôle
et c'est pas un hasard si les grands
hommes politiques ce qui dominent sont
des gens archi littéraires de Gaulle
Mitterrand Napoléon Napoléon mais on
pourrait dire Léon Blum ce sont des gens
extraordinairement pétri de littérature
et ils vont synthétiser si vous voulez
ce qu'on écrit les écrivains et donc je
mets dans les écrivains des gens comme
Michelet et les grands historiens et
c'est extraordinaire parce que lui on
voit bien cette opposition la France à
propos de la Révolution entre Michelet
qui en fait un conte de fées merveilleux
je fasse une vision romantique
l'histoire antique une vision poétique
et d'une réalité
qui a quand même eu des zones d'ombre
évidemment et Ethan qui lui nous montre
la révolution des réalités c'est-à-dire
de beaucoup d'horreur de beaucoup de
choisir vous choisissez lequel des deux
thèmes ou Michelet les deux parce que je
crois être français si on réfléchit un
peu si on se psychanalyse et bien on se
rend compte qu'on est divisé à
l'intérieur de nous-mêmes parce qu'on
est à la fois
on peut pas dire on peut pas rejeter
tout ce qu'a fait la monarchie il y a eu
des choses comme extraordinaire bon on
peut pas racheter complètement la
République
la révolution vous voyez donc on est
divisé c'est ce qui crée d'ailleurs ce
climat les diviser en tout quoi être
français
on était à la fois du côté des
protestants des Camisards qui ont été
maltraités on est du côté
d'une certaine façon des des
aristocrates comme on a révolution qui
ont été guillotinée une façon trop peu
pour injuste bon donc on est on partage
à la fois tous les enthousiasmes des
Français toutes leurs désillusions et au
fond on a une sorte d'incertitude sur ce
que nous sommes mais en même temps de
foi dans une idée qui est assez précise
qui est l'idée de la France dont on
parlait de Gaulle mais en même temps qui
assimile des choses contradictoires et
en fait donc vous êtes aussi
complètement d'accord avec Marc Bloch
dans cette phrase légendaire de
l'étrange des fêtes il est deux
catégories de Français qui ne
comprendront jamais l'histoire de France
ce qui refusent de vibrer le souvenir du
sacre de Reims ceux qui lisent sans
émotion le récit de la fête de la
Fédération ça c'est évidemment vous la
faites votre bien sûr parce que
je crois que le défaut des gens qui qui
parlent de l'histoire c'est le rugby de
contextualiser quand vous contextualisez
tous ces claires
Robespierre Danton au début de la
Révolution ils étaient monarchiste
il avait pas l'idée de tuer le roi donc
vous voyez quand on contextualise on se
rend compte que toutes les périodes de
l'histoire de France sont deviennent
beaucoup plus compréhensibles et
d'ailleurs François Mitterrand une
phrase sur l'époque vraiment tragique et
récente de guerre civile en France
c'est-à-dire l'occupation disait
l'opposition n'est pas entre résistant
et
vichyssois elle est entre ceux qui ont
connu cette période et ceux qui n'ont
pas connu et ceux qui ne l'ont pas connu
la juge souvent à l'aune de critères qui
sont pas bon idéologiques c'est-à-dire
de façon parce que ça c'est aussi le
défaut français c'est qu'on a gardé ce
côté disons guerre de religion on est
dans un on n'accepte pas l'autre et
c'est terrible c'est on a gardé ça de je
vous dis c'est des bûcher des il y a
quelque chose dans le fond français y
compris chez les laïcards au fond le
parti laïque en France qui est très fort
à thé bon et au fond c'est à repris des
accents religieux c'est pour ça on a
l'impression que ce sont des gens
défroqués mais qui ont repris quelque
chose de très violent de presque très
partisan d'ailleurs vous dites tout à
l'heure vous l'avez laissé entendre que
la laïcité est directement
issue quand même une espèce de morale de
la morale chrétienne aussi
contrairement à ce que pensent les Laïka
ils se rendent pas compte qu'au fond
c'est le christianisme qui a permis
puisque c'est le baptême de Clovis et
qui au lieu de choisir l'arianisme qui
lui donnait les pouvoirs spirituels et
temporel il a choisi le christianisme
qui lui séparait les deux bien sûr alors
vous avez écrit il y a quelques années
chez Grasset adieu en France qui s'en va
vous êtes nostalgique
écoutez la France d'aujourd'hui n'est
plus la France enfin c'est pas la France
que vous je fais tout pour le pas vivre
dans la nostalgie mais on peut pas s'en
empêcher parce que la France ne vivre
que dans le présent et nier le passé ça
serait
idiot parce que quand même il y a quand
même dans notre passé des choses
formidables donc j'adore le passé
j'adore le présent et je m'intéresse
passionnément à l'avenir bien sûr mais
mais ce passé
nous aurions tendance parce que nous
sommes aussi à cette autre défaut un
pays progressiste nous croyons au
progrès bon alors c'est sûr il y a des
domaines où le progrès est évident
médecine mais dans le domaine artistique
c'est ridicule il y a pas de progrès
artistique
les Grecs les Romains et la sculpture de
Rodin il y a une parenté il y a une
continuité donc mais je pense que ça
c'est ce côté progressif des Français
d'ailleurs il croit au progrès en tout
ils croient au progrès en politique
une amélioration alors bon on le voit
bien notre époque il y a quand même eu
bon des choses qui qui n'étaient pas
vraiment des progrès notamment en
matière de guerre oui donc je crois que
c'est progressiste il fait partie de
cette espèce d'aspiration des Français à
ce que l'avenir répare le présent et
répare le passé donc on est plus un pays
révolutionnaire qu'un pays conservateur
mais c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
c'est le mélange des deux c'est un pays
à la fois qui regardait regardez les
obsèques
en Angleterre
du prince Philippe les gens étaient
devant leur téléviseurs ils regardent et
c'était magnifique pour connaître je
suis sûr qu'il y avait au fond de
nous-mêmes on disait quand même la
République n'a pas réussi ces
enterrements n'a pas elle n'a pas de
rituel elle a un rituel très pauvre par
rapport à la monarchie et par rapport
aux Anglais et c'est vrai que de temps
en temps et moi je le sais parce que aux
Invalides qu'on voyait une cérémonie aux
Invalides
l'endroit traditionnel avec l'Académie
française d'ailleurs
mais disons c'est vrai on a besoin de la
tradition parce qu'on a besoin de se
dire que nous nous rattachons au fond à
ceux qui nous ont précédés et que nous
sommes leurs enfants qui ils nous ont
réglé quelque chose ça je crois
profondément ça c'est peut-être
aujourd'hui ce qui nous manque c'est
d'avoir conscience de ce que tout ce que
les générations précédentes nous ont
légué de merveilleux alors je vais vous
ai invité à écouter quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien je me fais un effet de
la France une certaine idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose
de très grand de très particulier
c'est du reste je le pense ressenti par
le monde entier
c'est vrai la France est une chose
à mes yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quel qu'il
soit tout époque naturellement d'après
les circonstances elle doit avoir un
rôle à elle il faut que la France joue
son rôle c'est exact et pour qu'elle
joue son rôle il faut qu'elle soit à la
France
les Français les Français ceux qui font
la France
c'est eux qui en sont responsables la
France c'est plus que les français du
moment
la France vient de loin
voilà c'était Charles de Gaulle donc
entre les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle la première au suffrage
universelle direct de 1965 où il était
opposé contre toute attente en ballotage
à François Mitterrand une phrase qui est
magnifique il y a un pacte
multicellulaire entre la grandeur de la
France et la liberté du monde et ça je
crois que là ça nous montre bien l'idée
qu'il se faisait et je crois qu'il a
raison c'est ma conception c'est ma
conception c'est que si vous voulez
cette il y a une civilisation française
beaucoup de gens qui le ni mais une
situation française qui est originale et
c'est ce qui explique que tant de gens
soient venus nous rejoindre parce que si
des écrivains comme Ionesco les Roumains
comme surront Romain Gary enfin on va
pas faire le nombre des écrivains qui
sont venus nous rejoindre des artistes
c'est Picasso c'est parce qu'ils avaient
compris que il y avait la France
un héritage qui nous vient des Grecs et
des christianisme qui est
l'universalisme et aussi un autre
élément qui vient également de c'est la
vérité par la beauté la vérité par la
beauté et ça c'est une singularité
française complètement complètement et
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire vous
savez moi je suis pas chauvin moi
j'adore les écrivains je les rues
Tolstoï les Américains enfin bon mais il
faut bien se reconnaître que c'est pour
ça je crois beaucoup aux nations je
crois que comme De Gaulle de ce point de
vue là très rigoliste et que chaque pays
a ses particularités et qui bien sûr en
ce moment sont sont très menacés parce
que c'est vrai qu'on la mondialisation
et c'est d'effacer les particularités et
moi je crois que chacun doit avoir sa
particularité mais qu'est-ce qu'un
écrivain
c'est quelqu'un qui a une vision un
écrivain un peintre qui a une vision
particulière et cette vision
particulière
étrangement elle va devenir universelle
et on va devenir tous un petit Picasso
un Manet un Tolstoï et tous ces
écrivains avaient en eux des amorces et
des ferments de l'universel que nous
rejoignons dans un homme finalement
l'homme universel alors vous avez écrit
un livre justement il y a pas longtemps
qui parle beaucoup de ça et qui parle de
justement de notre c'est le pays des
hommes sans Dieu face justement à une
menace qui pourrait être la menace et
qui est la menace islamiste notamment
vous dites on sait pas se défendre et on
sait surtout pas se poser face à cette à
cette agression parce que on a
complètement perdu justement et bien la
notion de Dieu
non c'était disons accessoirement une
petite pierre dans le jardin
des gens qui considèrent que que la
religion néfaste et que la laïcité est
la seule réponse moi je crois que c'est
faux je veux pas leur dire que c'est
faux pour moi c'est une erreur c'est une
erreur je pense que
on a besoin de religion tout le monde a
besoin de la religion et y compris les
mêmes les athées certaines façons ils
croient en quelque chose ils croient on
va dire quoi je ne partage pas leur
vision mais enfin et mais ce livre
surtout ce qui d'essayer de montrer
c'était la pauvrissement de la France
dans la mesure où il y en a pas
vomissement religieux alors moi
famille catholique mais je suis
pratiquant je vous dis franchement mais
mais je me rends compte que je suis
culturellement et c'est un apport d'être
chrétien si vous ne suivez pas le
catéchisme si vous ne suivez pas
l'histoire des religions vous ne
comprendrez pas grand chose quand vous
irez au musée du Louvre quand vous irez
à Venise vous ne comprendrez rien donc
je pense que pour nous-mêmes
moi je crois que ça pose un problème
pour l'État à partir du moment où une
langue un bon ça peut entraîner
justement des une sorte de de création
d'une amorce d'une nation
je crois que c'est très bien d'avoir la
nation française il faut pas qu'il y a
d'autres concurrence mais sur le plan de
la langue c'est vrai que je trouve c'est
très riche et
mais je me suis battu alors là je
préfère voir des beaux basques des beaux
corses bien sûr dans notre langue plutôt
que du franglais voilà ça a été mon
combat vraiment et c'est de voir la
dénaturation de la langue française sous
l'effet de du frontlet et surtout
l'impuissance et la négligence des
pouvoirs publics qui qui n'ont pas
appliqué la loi tout bon qui essayait de
de limiter cette
invasion qui fait que comme dirait
Gilles de Brenne nous sommes devenus des
galericains et bien je pense que ça
c'est un combat qui est très utile alors
le rayonnement de la France c'est le
président de Gaulle qui disait que la
France a un rôle a joué dans le monde
elle a un rôle à jouer à travers sa
langue justement à travers la
francophonie vous vous êtes un écrivain
Académie française est-ce que vous
trouvez que la francophonie joue
suffisamment son rôle dans ce point de
vue
alors la Francophonie qui n'est pas que
la France il faut le dire sur très
important mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il a sous ton
comment voulez-vous que la francophonie
puisse marcher si les Français eux-mêmes
parlent un sabbir qui est un mélange
d'anglais non
et c'est pas possible comment
voulez-vous que la francophonie puisse
marcher si on attribue pas à tout ce qui
est les valeurs culturelles
si on ne considère pas comme quelque
chose d'important donc
il faut voir le paysage dans lequel nous
vivons je veux pas parler du paysage
télévisuel mais enfin le paysage non
n'est pas un paysage culturel et surtout
il y a une disons une détérioration de
la conception que nous avions de la du
livre et de la littérature maintenant on
mélange tout on mélange le livre la
littérature ce qui n'a pardon mais c'est
très différent parce que qu'est-ce qui a
fait les piliers fondamentaux de
l'histoire de France de l'histoire de
notre pays ça a été les écrivains la
littérature bien sûr le livre est
maintenant par la voie des
best-sellers voyons encore un mot
anglais
on mélange tout et on ne se rend pas
compte on attribue plus une valeur
fondamentale aux écrivains et alors ça
va sur le plan d'éducation on considère
que les grands écrivains Balzac sont des
vieillis et ça c'est très très
dommageable et ce qui fait qu'il n'y a
plus cette espèce de feu de force qui
était dans la civilisation française qui
faisait qu'elle convertissait des gens à
la langue française donc je pense que
nous avons nous manquons terriblement en
matière de culture d'ailleurs on le voit
dans l'affaissement des instituts
culturels on les a bazardés d'une façon
lamentable donc il y a plus de volonté
comme on les Allemands les Allemands
avec les goûts instituts ils sont très
dynamiques nous nous sommes plus
dynamiques dans ce domaine de la
propagation non seulement de notre
langue parce que c'est pas seulement une
langue ce qu'il faut c'est aussi une
civilisation alors vous êtes un homme de
combat
vous détestez les injustices et les
combats vous savez les mener le combat
que vous avez mené pour
Omar Haddad
vous êtes aussi engagés quand Françoise
Sagan a eu affaire avec le fils que vous
étiez là et ça c'est un combat que vous
pourriez mener justement sur la
francophonie la défense de la langue
dans tout le monde
bien sûr mais enfin vous savez je veux
pas multiplier combat je veux pas
devenir donc il choque voilà il faut pas
jouer voilà maintenant je me suis limité
à quelques combats voilà notamment celui
que vous venez d'évoquer sur ma radar
qui j'espère aboutira parce que
la justice c'est l'image de la France le
monde entier la France
est assez représentation du pays de la
justice parce qu'il y a Montesquieu
parce que et puis on se rend compte
qu'il a été fasciné par l'affaire
Dreyfus aussi
façonner oui oui bien sûr mais on se
rend compte que très souvent bah la
justice en France elle a été menée aussi
beaucoup par les écrivains c'est
Voltaire c'est Victor Hugo
si vous voulez ce combat bien sûr ce
combat pour la défense de la
civilisation française c'est vrai mais
disons
celui là j'explique le nez par on
écrivant moi-même des livres qui qui
peuvent donner une bonne image j'ai fait
ce que je peux mais l'image disons de ce
qu'est la langue française est-ce qu'il
y a un risque à leur certain il y a un
grand débat depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
en Europe et en France sur justement
l'institution européenne l'Union
européenne est-ce que en étant un des
piliers de cette union européenne la
France avec un président actuellement
qui est très pro européen ce qui a un
risque justement que notre civilisation
européenne et bien
soit d'une certaine façon se dit seul
dans cet ensemble c'est tout le problème
c'est tout le problème mais et c'est
très embêtant parce que la fois nous
sommes progressistes donc nous sommes
nous allons vers l'Europe mais c'est
vrai moi je serai plutôt vous l'avez
compris du côté de Gaulle et de l'Europe
des nations l'ordination je crois que
chacun doit garder phrase vous avez si
goet n'avait pas été allemand et bien
ils ont écrit dans un vol a pu
qu'intégrer c'est vrai je crois que
chaque nation intérêt à garder ces
personnalités même si bien sûr il y a
des accords des échanges bien entendu ça
c'est les accords les échanges c'est la
vie c'est ce point-là c'est l'Europe
mais il faudrait faire attention que
l'Europe ne soit pas un petit défaut les
Français c'est-à-dire le grand rêve
impossible et finalement on est ravi de
de résoudre les problèmes de la réalité
dans un rêve on un rêve qui ne mange pas
de pain parce que on voit pas les très
bien les résultats regardez sur le
nombre sur le plan concret le nombre de
choses que depuis le temps qu'on est
dans l'Europe qui sont qui n'ont pas
avancé d'un pas été résolu donc si vous
voulez c'est un peu disons la fumée
c'est un peu la fumée de la seiche vous
savez qui est plutôt le
un danger la sèche est aimé de l'encre
comme ça pour se dissimuler alors
Jean-Marie alors je vais vous demander
de vous livrer un petit exercice que
vous connaissez le questionnaire de
Proust si la France c'était une toile ça
serait quoi
je crois que ça serait
moi je vous dirais un paysage de coraux
et le pont de menthe le pont de menthe
Mantes-la-Jolie c'est une beauté
et mais seulement vous savez je crois
que la France est tombée violente donc
je dirais c'est aussi l'Olympia de
manège c'est aussi il y a d'autres
choses parce que on ne peut pas demander
une réponse pour la France et les
doubles elle est toujours double vous
avez on dit c'est ça parce que ça c'est
une image de modération mais on pourrait
dire que la France c'est quelquefois
c'est de la Croix c'est-à-dire c'est une
forme de violence la Liberté guidant le
peuple voilà exactement donc je pense
que c'est très mais enfin pour moi je
crois que c'est ce caractère paisible de
la France
si c'était un paysage un paysage je
crois que paysage qui est presque
fondateur de ce que la France c'était
les Pays de la Loire c'est la vallée de
la Loire et voilà
la douceur et puis et puis la grandeur
parce que c'est l'art sur Ajouter la
nature vous avez les châteaux
extraordinaires Amboise non il y a
toujours dans un paysage français c'est
ça qui dit oui c'est pour ça que c'est
un modèle c'est que il y a les paysages
extraordinaires et en même temps l'homme
il rajoutait les chefs
un écrivain ça serait qui
alors un écrivain
justement je pense que je prendrai
Romain Gary ah parce que Romain Gary est
étranger mais converti à la France moi
je trouve qu'un converti c'est
formidable parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
qui était dans son pays et il a réussi à
être converti tout en gardant l'âme
russe
et c'est un homme que je trouve d'un
grand courage et puis il était mal vu
par le monde intellectuel le monde
littéraire vous avez un ouvrage en
particulier chez Gary qui vous à la
promesse de l'aube la promesse de l'aube
alors là je crois que moi je voudrais le
donner à chaque enfant de 18 ans le
distribué voilà pour qu'il puisse
comprendre ce qu'est la France vraiment
ce qu'est la France est-ce que c'est que
la vie parce que en même temps c'est un
roman d'initiation et on voit cette vie
cette fille qui rêve cette France qui
rêve dans sa très très beau livre
personnage historique
très embêté parce que historique je
dirais Napoléon Napoléon et en même
temps je suis gêné puisque je suis très
pacifié et mais il est fondateurs ils
font une nouvelle France avec la
Révolution la France était mise par
terre parce que c'est tout acheté lié à
la monarchie et au christianisme et donc
ils font une nouvelle France et là
encore il le dit il a une phrase de lui
il dit je fais mes plans de bataille
avec les rêves de mes soldats endormis
je crois qu'il a très bien exprimé cette
volonté française que de Gaulle
retrouvera plus tard en faisant cette
forme de monarchielective c'est-à-dire
que les Français sont tellement divisés
qu'ils ont besoin d'un chef ils ont
besoin d'un chef il y a la culture du
chef
depuis l'origine droite ou gauche
parce qu'on se dit au fond les Français
sont pas tellement des intellectuels
vous savez quand
moi personnellement je comprends rien
mais enfin je pense qu'ils comprennent
pas mieux que moi et donc il vaut mieux
être bien qui fera voilà ben et c'est
vrai la politique c'est pas de la
théorie le théorie toutes les théories
disparu voilà on a quelques exemples
elle se elle s'abîme avec le temps voilà
au lavage se réduisent là-bas donc 10
fois tu bien c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
accepté aussi bien des gens comme
comme De Gaulle puis ensuite Mitterrand
comme Giscard vous voyez il s'adapte et
voilà ils ont choisi le type qui leur
paraissait le plus apte c'est une
politique dans l'intérêt de la France
Merci Jean-Marie avoir merci beaucoup
[Musique]